[Applause]
and finally newal as an Ivy League
graduate who knows the value of a
liberal education I have one piece of
advice for the Youth of America don't go
to
college and if you absolutely have to go
don't go to an elite College because as
recent events have shown it just makes
you
stupid there are few if any positives to
come out of what happened in Israel but
one of them is opening America's eyes to
how higher education has become
indoctrination into a stew of bad ideas
among them the simplistic notion that
the world is a binary place where
everyone is either an oppressor or
oppressed in the case of Israel
oppressors being babies and Bubbas the
same students who will tell you that
words or violence and silence as
violence were very supportive when Hamas
terrorists went on a rape and murder
Rampage worthy of the Vikings they knew
where to point the fingers at the
murdered and then it was off to ethics
class
now now I recognize that a certain
amount of foolishness is expected of
college kids but mixing Jagermeister and
tomato juice isn't the same as siding
with
terrorists 34 student groups at Harvard
signed a letter that said the apari
regime is the only one to blame proving
they don't know what constitutes a part
that they don't know much of anything
actually but it doesn't deter them from
having an opinion they've convinced
themselves Israel is the most repressive
regime in history because they have no
knowledge of history or even a desire to
know it an actual history doesn't come
up in their intersectionality of
politics and gender queer identities
[Applause]
[Music]
class now to be fair at least five of
the student groups have rescinded what
they signed saying they didn't read the
letter
closely and they promised not to make
that mistake again after they graduate
and start running the
world
but I I actually believe them that they
didn't read the letter closely I think
they scanned it said it was blaming
Israel and went back to surfing Tik
Tock because college life today
is a day spot combined with a North
Korean reeducation Camp it's a daycare
center with a meal plan except the
toddlers can fire the adults the fact
that college presidents who usually
loved to speak out about anything
couldn't find their voice to condemn the
worst attacks and the Holocaust is a lot
about who really controls colleges and
why if ignorance is is a disease Harvard
Yard is the Wuhan wet
Market
not that colleges didn't always have
professors with radical beliefs I know I
used to sell them
weed but the reason why despising Israel
became pretty much a requirement of the
American left is colleges Elite colleges
the mouth of the River from which this
and all manner of radical left illiberal
yes illiberal nonsense flows supporting
all black that is segregated dorms
segregated graduation ceremonies and
orientation programs which occur on
hundreds of campuses is illiberal so is
the racism against Asian applicants and
chasing speakers off of
Campus when the first amendment Watchdog
group foundation for indiv indvidual
rights and expression began ranking
colleges based on their commitment to
free speech and inquiry Harvard came in
dead last there's only one set of
acceptable opinions on campus and it's
policed hard the old dorm room bull
sessions it's less risky shooting the
in
Scientology John John Stewart Mill wrote
that he who knows only his own side of
the case knows little to which today's
college students respond he and his are
CIS
pronouns that commit violence against
queer and bipac communi so who cares
what John Stewart Mill says whoever he
is oh and Thomas Jefferson was a
slaveholder he might have done some
other stuff but it wasn't on the
test
Elite schools should no longer be called
Elite just say
expensive which may be why they breed a
particular brand of detestable graduate
a personality type that does not emerge
from Chico State
sure they occasionally turn out someone
decent but for every Barack Obama there
are two Josh
holes the former debate team jerk off
who had no friends that no one likes
today and yet somehow manages to win a
Statewide popularity contest box
checking brownnosers who don't actually
believe anything except that tricking
stupid people's fun
that's
that's that's why it is so repulsive
when they Pander for votes from Mama
June and the flat earthers because they
just hate
elitists yeah look at these truck
driving he men from the tul a at Sam's
Club V ramaswami Yale and Harvard Ronda
santis Yale and Harvard Ted Cruz
Princeton and Harvard Pat Robertson
George W bush Tom Cotton Mike Mike
Pompeo Bill O'Reilly Steve Bannon Jared
Kushner most of the Supreme Court
there's a special magic that links
Harvard types and being utterly face
punchable and some I assume are good
people
and while it may seem like these men men
like these and the kids who signed the
Harvard letter have nothing in common
actually I think they do they all came
out of an
Factory
so
so to the older folks I say college
today is not the college you remember
and to the younger people I say don't
don't do it
you don't need four years in a lifetime
of crippling debt to learn to hate
America when you can just watch 5
minutes of selling
Sunset if your parents have 300 Grand
they absolutely need to flush down the
toilet put it in crypto or buy a van go
to a national park and feed yourself to
a bear
because any Legacy can go to pen
but a bear that's hard to get
into